before the Twitter files came out my law
firm and the center for American Liberty
sued Twitter and a host of other parties
including California Secretary of State
for this very thing and they
um it was revealed after the 2020
election that California my government
right which I pay a lot of taxes to was
using those tax dollars enemies along
the enemies as our client Rogan o'hanley
AKA DC Drano who was just reinstated on
Twitter last week our lawsuit is ongoing
all right so before we get into all of
that Nitty Gritty that you mentioned
earlier just a little bit more on on the
big Tech stuff and Free Speech because
obviously we're seeing all of the
Twitter files dumping right now at the
same time we're also seeing the
mainstream Media or the corporate press
whatever you want to call them we're
seeing them completely ignore it so our
Divergence between the people that
believe one thing and the people that
believe another thing is just getting
wider and wider and wider do you think
anything will actually come out of these
leaks I mean beyond the fact that a
certain amount of people will wake up do
you think that there will be legal
action either against the U.S government
or further action against Twitter and
and does that then push things down so
that uh you know down the road so that
YouTube and Google and Facebook and
everybody else might start getting
looked at in a different way as well
well there is action against the US
government and Eric Schmidt attorney
general and and some others are filing
suit before the Twitter files came out
my law firm and the center for American
Liberty sued Twitter and a host of other
parties including California Secretary
of State for this very thing and they
um it was revealed after the 2020
election that California my government
right which I pay a lot of taxes to was
using those tax dollars enemies long the
enemies as our client Rogan o'hanley AKA
DC Drano who was just reinstated on
Twitter last week our lawsuit is ongoing
that kind of litigation is ongoing but
the courts are not receptive to it at
this time you know we lost that case in
the district court we argued in the
ninth circuit you win or lose based on
the perspective of the judges who are on
the court frankly so what is needed in
my opinion to really reform the
situation is for Republicans to win
elections Republicans have to win
elections and it has to be the right
Republicans if you actually had the you
know
out of touch crew who's in the
Republican Congress and Senate right now
those were the same people who were in
The Republican Congress and Senate when
we had the White House in 2017 and 2018
those were the leaders they did nothing
to address social media censorship we
need to elect new and better Republicans
who get it we need to reform
Communications decency act section 230
to not allow basically a free pass to
all kinds of torts and contract
violations that courts are ignoring
under the Aegis of 230 and then we need
to create in my opinion of social media
users what do you say to the counter
argument on the 230 argument we've
discussed that a lot on the show that
some people will say well if you take
away some of those protections that then
you'll actually hamper Free Speech
because the platforms will feel that
they are more responsible and then
they'll have to go after everybody to
make sure everything's you know clean or
okay yeah
I don't I I'm not advocating the removal
of 230. I don't I don't agree with that
there is a provision of it that says
that uh social media companies can
remove content that is quote unquote
otherwise objectionable so it isn't in
an enumerated list they use that
otherwise objectionable to say uh
vaccine information that's contrary to
what fauci says they use that as an
excuse to censor things that they the
social media company want to suppress or
manipulate or worse as we're learning
through the Twitter files they let our
government do that without disclosing it
no I do not think that was the meaning
of section 230 at all and Congress can
make that clear the law is old 1996 law
passed to actually protect social media
companies it's an out of control monster
and one of the reasons that Dave that
you say that you know there's sort of a
lack of responsiveness by the mainstream
media on these issues the mainstream
media has actually been crippled by dint
of the social media companies having
rights and privileges to say and do
whatever they want whereas the
traditional media doesn't have those
rights and privileges in a way CDA 230
has really weaponized the growth of
these the the the unaccountability of
these big social media companies
um and so I think there are some tweaks
that could be done without empowering
the government empowering the users
there should be a social media users
Bill of Rights that says that if they
change the terms on you if they ban you
or suppress you for reasons that they
did not disclose in advance you have a
right to sue them we have rights like
that with respect to pharmaceutical
products products that blow up cars that
don't work we have those rights with
commercial products this is a commercial
product I'm paying to use Twitter I
should have some rights with respect to
Twitter
so what would you say I I've actually I
know you do some work obviously with Ron
Coleman who's been on the show many
times
um and we discussed this once on air if
I was to find out for example that the
government directly had contacted
Twitter to take down the tweet that I
had back in July of 2021 saying that
vaccine mandates were coming and
vaccines were not working uh as they as
promised etc etc
if I was to find out if through these
Twitter files or whatever it might be
that that actually it was because of a
government agent telling Twitter to take
it down what is what is the reward for
someone other than that maybe the
government would acknowledge it can you
sue the government like can you be like
well I want 10 million bucks because you
guys infringe on my free speech or is it
just purely just yeah we screwed up it's
back up and nobody gets fired this is
the government
well we have been suing the government
the case I just described is like that
and in the ninth circuit I think we ran
into a uh let's just say we haven't
received the ruling yet but it was not a
favorable reception in the ninth circuit
I pray that in fact at the end of the
day these Twitter files actually started
to come out after the hearing and so
maybe you know the clerks and the judges
will see that wait whoa this is actually
a huge deal it isn't this isn't a
one-off this is actually a whole system
that's been exposed
a case like that filed in a different
Court might have succeeded but actually
under Twitter's terms of service you
have to file it here in California you
know so it's it's it's been a challenge
I'm confident that over time there will
be a case that breaks through that says
that this is a violation of the first
amendment I do think it is there are
some First Amendment lawyers who say oh
no the companies can do whatever they
want it was merely a strong suggestion
from the government but here right right
files Twitter was actually being paid by
the FBI I mean I don't know how you can
deny that that's government action it's
government action obviously so I'm sorry
I'm very animated about it but I'm
shocked that judges aren't picking this
up right well also if the government was
to call me if I got a call from a
government agent saying Dave we're not
telling you to do anything but just FYI
we've been watching the show and you've
been saying a lot about that I might
take that as a as a threat or some sort
of yeah that's why the the gray area
here obviously is where the the real
stuff is right I mean or you know nice
social media presence and show you have
shame if something were to happen to it
or you know maybe there's an audit you
know like literally the government has
so much power over us
um we're seeing it with January 6th
stuff I mean they can
make crime and harass you and so this is
not trivial to me and by the way I as a
First Amendment lawyer I would stand up
for the rights of some leftists to be
able to say whatever they want on social
media
short of threats of violence that are
true threats or other violations of
enumerated parts of the 230 pornography
and things like that
um
but that does not seem to be reciprocal
the left has entirely abandoned the
principle of due process equal
protection for speech issues on the
right the ACLU no longer supports Free
Speech they don't they don't support you
being able to talk about gun use I mean
it is it is a 180 and it is just a
wholly awoke
woke Endeavor now and so we the right
have become the engine of free speech
and even on our side people don't get it
so I'd love to see a whole Revolution on
our side about these issues
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell